So am I erasing myself? Hope I'm not erasing myself. I guess it would be nice to give my heart to a god. But which one, which one do I? Psycho or confused? I just want to hold it in. All right, I'm here with Dr. Leilich, who's a professor emeritus. And I was like, I'm trying to catch, you know, I've seen you in every cult documentary almost, I think, that I've ever seen. And then we'll catch you on different podcasts and things.
所以我是在抹杀自我吗？希望我没有在抹杀自我。我想把心交给一位神或许不错。但交给哪一位呢？我该选哪一个？是精神错乱还是困惑？我只是想把它守住。好了，我和莱利希博士在一起，他是名誉教授。我当时想，我得赶上进度，你知道，我几乎在每一部关于邪教的纪录片里都见过你。然后我们会在不同的播客和节目中看到你。
I was a comparative religion major and, you know, do therapy now. So a lot of trauma and high control group stuff. So same kind of world uh so of my interest and your interest i've encountered you but i was trying to make sure like oh let me catch up and make sure i didn't miss anything big and it seems like you may be more busy retired than when you were teaching full time i don't know how you keep up with the schedule and i think like the cult i mean you one if people want to hear what you have to say on this stuff you've written about it for a long
我主修比较宗教学，现在从事心理治疗工作。所以接触了很多创伤和高控制群体相关的内容。所以这是同一个领域，也是我的兴趣所在，也是你的兴趣所在，我遇到过你。但我当时想确认一下，哦，让我补补课，确保我没有错过什么大事。看起来你退休后比全职教学时还要忙，我不知道你是怎么跟上这个节奏的。而且我觉得，关于邪教，如果你想听听别人对这些事情的看法，你已经写了很长一段时间了，
time and you also are in almost any you know documentary where they might encounter that stuff so they i would my worst fear with something like this is to get a guest that said something a million times really well and then not absorb that information and be like could you just give us clip notes just tell us again you know so but you also want to give people some kind of intro into what you do so i've always kind of try and get somebody to reconsider their work from a new perspective or a bigger thing and i mean you've been going around since the 70s the weather underground which was a culty time you know the seventies economic malaise and people are attracted to this esoteric power. You know, one of my interests is like, do you feel like, I mean, there are definitely things like the internet and the fusion of self-help with multi-level marketing,
而且你几乎出现在任何可能涉及这些内容的纪录片中。我最担心的是，找一个把同样的话说了无数遍的嘉宾，结果却没能吸收那些信息，然后问：你能给我们讲讲要点吗？再告诉我们一遍。但你同时也想给人们介绍一下你的工作，所以我总是试图让别人从新的角度或更大的层面重新审视他们的工作。从70年代开始，你就一直在关注这些，比如“地下气象员”，那是一个邪教盛行的时期，你知道，七十年代的经济低迷，人们被这种深奥的力量所吸引。你知道，我的兴趣之一是，你是否觉得，我是说，确实存在像互联网、自我提升与多层次传销的融合，
with social media, with everything that just changed the technology, make some things available that weren't there before right so that's that's happening but do you feel like we are going back to a time where the disillusionment with you know right left politics and um the kind of atomization of people not feeling like we're part of the same project anymore of being very polarized or not even polarized because even people on the same sides don't quite agree or don't speak the same language. Does it feel like the seventies again to you? You know, I was born in 87, so I missed it. You know, I'm going to fall to your perspective on this. Well, I think that a lot of what happened, I mean, a lot of this change in the
以及社交媒体等一切改变了技术的东西，让一些以前不存在的东西变得触手可及，对吧？所以这些都在发生。但你是否觉得我们正在回到一个对左右翼政治感到幻灭的时代？人们不再觉得我们是同一个项目的一部分，变得非常两极分化，甚至连两极分化都算不上，因为即使是同一阵营的人也不完全同意对方，或者说不讲同一种语言。这对你来说感觉像七十年代吗？你知道，我出生于87年，所以我错过了那个时代。你知道，我得听听你的看法。嗯，我认为发生了很多事情，我是说，这种环境的改变，
environment of cults and high control groups, you know, happened during the pandemic, the year we were sheltered in. And because everybody was pecking around on their computers and, you know, and that's the, I thought I was retiring. And then I suddenly got hundreds of emails like, you know, my uncle, I don't want to invite my uncle to Thanksgiving. I can't talk to my sister anymore, you know, conspiracy theories, anti-vaxxers q anon all that stuff and so i think the internet the access to the internet has absolutely expanded the environment um so that there are more internet-based cults than ever before um which which has changed things
邪教和高控制群体的环境，你知道，是在疫情期间，我们居家隔离的那一年发生的。因为每个人都在电脑上敲敲打打，你知道，我本以为我要退休了。然后我突然收到了几百封邮件，比如，你知道，我叔叔，我不想邀请我叔叔参加感恩节。我再也无法和我妹妹沟通了，你知道，阴谋论、反疫苗者、匿名者Q，所有这些东西。所以我认为互联网，对互联网的访问绝对扩大了这种环境，所以现在基于互联网的邪教比以往任何时候都多，这改变了事情，
in a way for someone like me because because before you always, you know, you knew where the cult was, you knew where the headquarters was, you knew who the leader was, you knew maybe where their satellites were, but now it's so amorphous. So for example, with QAnon, like who was the leader of QAnon? Was it that guy and his son? Was it, you know, and, and so that, that makes it a little more difficult on one level. Well, there are multiple people claiming to be the original leader and followed as the original leader, while most scholars feel like the original guy is probably gone.
对于像我这样的人来说，因为以前你总是知道邪教在哪里，你知道总部在哪里，你知道领导者是谁，你可能知道他们的卫星机构在哪里，但现在它太模糊了。例如，以匿名者Q为例，谁是匿名者Q的领导者？是那个家伙和他的儿子吗？是，你知道，所以这在某种程度上让事情变得更困难了。嗯，有很多人声称自己是最初的领导者，并被追随为最初的领导者，而大多数学者认为最初的那个人可能已经不在了。
He did his fun and somebody else is playing with the internet-based cults and this past, I don't know, five years or so, is that the cults, those cults or those high control groups, whatever you want to call them, are far more polarized and because of this, what we call us versus them environment, which I believe the former president, whose name I shall not mention, did a lot to encourage that us versus them mentality. So that, you know, the anti-vaxxers, the white supremacists, whoever, you know, I think we can all remember the cases where, you know, you'd go into a store and someone would rip your mask off or, you know. And there'd be somebody next to you saying,
他完成了他的使命，现在有别人在玩弄这些基于互联网的邪教。过去这五年左右，这些邪教，或者说那些高控制群体，无论你怎么称呼它们，都更加两极分化。因为这种我们所说的“我们对他们”的环境，我相信前总统（我不提他的名字）在鼓励这种“我们对他们”的心态方面做了很多工作。所以，你知道，反疫苗者、白人至上主义者，无论谁，你知道，我想我们都能记得那些案例，你知道，你走进一家商店，有人会扯掉你的口罩，或者，你知道。旁边会有人说，
well, I'm wearing five masks. So look how virtuous I am where everyone was taking it to, to kind of an antagonistic extreme. Right. But the, the difference I think today is that the, a lot of these groups act outward, they act out against society, which in the past, most cults didn't do that and don't do that. We had a few cases like Aum Shinrikyo, the cult in Japan that put the sarin gas in the subway, but most cults basically ruin the lives of their own members. They don't so much have anything to do with the outside society. And so this is a real difference. They don't want to be seen. That's a threat. If you expose it, then it looks, you know, for the lack of a better word, kind of crazy. So you want to say, no, no, we just want to clap for the guy on the stage and say,
嗯，我戴了五个口罩。所以看看我有多高尚，每个人都把它推向了一种对抗性的极端。没错。但我认为今天不同的是，许多这些群体采取向外的行动，他们针对社会采取行动，而在过去，大多数邪教并不这样做，也不会这样做。我们有一些案例，比如奥姆真理教，那个在日本地铁里投放沙林毒气的邪教，但大多数邪教基本上只是毁了他们成员自己的生活。他们与外部社会并没有太多关系。所以这是一个真正的区别。他们不想被看到。那是一种威胁。如果你揭露它，那么它看起来，你知道，用一个更好的词来说，有点疯狂。所以你想说，不，不，我们只是想为台上的那个人鼓掌，说，
oh, we learned such great things. Thank you for all you did. Just don't say what he did, or you can't see what those are, but we just want to show you how happy we are. Right, exactly. And the the difference today is the the um the growth of the outward violence um and and that's obviously very troubling um and it seems like that's because it's a decentralized thing like it isn't like there's even if there's a q anon guy or whatever it's not like they're going into the meeting and he's saying okay stacy you do this this week then you do that someone's just reading this language on the internet they're listening to Alex Jones he says that the pizza restaurant's part of it maybe I gravitate to that this person says whatever and then I decide oh my
哦，我们学到了很棒的东西。谢谢你所做的一切。只是不要说他做了什么，或者你不能看到那些是什么，但我们只是想向你展示我们有多快乐。没错，完全正确。而今天不同的是，向外暴力行为的增长，这显然非常令人不安。而且这似乎是因为它是一个去中心化的东西，不像是有个匿名者Q的家伙或者其他什么，不是说他们去开会，然后他说，好吧，斯泰西，你这周做这个，然后你做那个。有人只是在互联网上阅读这些语言，他们听亚历克斯·琼斯的节目，他说披萨店是其中的一部分，也许我会被吸引到那里，这个人说这个，那个人说那个，然后我决定，哦，天哪，
gosh I'm gonna go out and do something right you know is that a high control group and that I am internalizing all this information but it's not a top-down mafia structure of, these are the orange belt, red belt, black belt. You know, it's not an exeum. That's the difference. So this kind of, I mean, in a way, those people are under the same kind of influence that we see in the cultic groups. But, again, you can't put your hand on it. And before, you always needed personal contact to get recruited into something. But now,
我要出去做点什么，对吧？你知道，那是一个高控制群体吗？我正在内化所有这些信息，但它不是那种自上而下的黑手党结构，比如，这是橙带、红带、黑带。你知道，它不是像NXIVM那样。这就是区别。所以这种，我是说，在某种程度上，这些人受到了我们在邪教群体中看到的同样的影响。但是，同样，你无法触及它。而在以前，你总是需要个人接触才能被招募到某个组织中。但现在，
as we were saying, it happens by somebody logging into something and thinking, Oh, that's really cool. And they start believing that. And so there's viral or memetic in a way. You have an idea of virus and a, you have idea viruses and real viruses sort of making each other's job
正如我们所说，它发生于某人登录某个东西并认为，哦，那真的很酷。然后他们开始相信这一点。所以它在某种程度上是病毒式的或模因式的。你有一种思想病毒，而思想病毒和真正的病毒在某种程度上让彼此的工作
easier, which I don't know. I wish that the last season had a better writer, I guess. Yeah. So it's kind of a new world in that sense and pretty frightening. I mean, I keep saying, God, I'm sure glad I don't have kids because I wouldn't want my kid to go to school these days. You know, the atmosphere in our country is pretty volatile well but i think in the same way that i mean as someone who does have kids not that it isn't very
变得更容易，我不知道。我希望上一季的编剧能写得更好一些。是的。所以从这个意义上说，这是一个新世界，而且相当可怕。我是说，我一直说，天哪，我真庆幸我没有孩子，因为我不想让我的孩子在这些日子里去上学。你知道，我们国家的氛围相当不稳定。嗯，但我认为以同样的方式，我是说，作为一个有孩子的人，并不是说它不
incredibly scary but like you do see you know the the 50s advertising doesn't work on the person from the 60s you know now i don't want the american dream i want to be the man from the future who drinks vodka and my deodorant sprays from a can and you know like you know and then the 60s advertising looks quaint the next time you do see kids that are making jokes essentially about like religion and social control and um you know the role of charismatic leaders politically and whatever at like 10 now you know that's what they're joking about and it's things that completely had their you know parents or who were older millennials or boomers totally under you know they didn't have those resistances until they were 30 40 you know because culture moving at light speed means that you know
非常可怕，但你确实看到，你知道，50年代的广告对60年代的人不起作用，你知道，现在我不想要美国梦，我想成为那个喝伏特加、除臭剂从罐子里喷出来的未来男人，你知道，然后60年代的广告在下一次看起来就很古雅了。你确实看到孩子们基本上在开关于宗教和社会控制的玩笑，以及，你知道，魅力型领导者在政治上的角色等等，现在才10岁，你知道，这就是他们在开的玩笑，这些事情完全让他们的父母，或者那些年长的千禧一代或婴儿潮一代完全处于，你知道，他们在30、40岁之前都没有那种抵触情绪，你知道，因为文化以光速移动意味着，你知道，
we're looking at you know two and five years is almost like a generational gap now and cultural awareness and experience yeah yeah so it's a different world. That's for sure. I mean, I'm, yeah, I'm almost 79 years old and I'm like, wow, you know, even just tipping, I mean, you know what we went through to get me the link for this, you know, it's like, you know, you know, so. When you, when you look at like the way that you've been in all of these documentaries, you know, you don't say it, but, you know, you may agree or like certain ones of them more like how your footage is used or something. I mean, the true criming of cults, essentially in high control groups, getting them getting the true crime sensationalist treatment. I mean, I think in one way it does give people those tools like kids
我们现在看到的，你知道，两到五年几乎就像是一个代沟，在文化意识和经验方面。是的，是的，所以这是一个不同的世界。那是肯定的。我是说，我，是的，我快79岁了，我当时想，哇，你知道，甚至只是给小费，我是说，你知道我们经历了什么才让我得到这个链接，你知道，这就像，你知道，你知道，所以。当你，当你看到你出现在所有这些纪录片中的方式时，你知道，你没有说出来，但，你知道，你可能会同意或更喜欢其中的某些，比如你的镜头是如何被使用的，或者其他什么。我是说，邪教的“真实犯罪化”，本质上是在高控制群体中，让他们受到真实犯罪耸人听闻的处理。我是说，我认为在某种程度上它确实给了人们那些工具，比如孩子们
are making jokes about this stuff now my wife didn't turn the nexium documentary off fast enough when my daughter was pretending to be asleep and was like you know mom what's a sex cult and we like we both looked at each other so um so like you know anyway they they have in one way it's good that you're exposing what goes on inside of this stuff and its effect on people but then it also is kind of sensationalizing and othering and there's some other risks associated with it i mean one is kind of victim blaming but another is pretending like oh look at this weird group look what they do yeah i feel like when those movies work you saying, this is the norm for human behavior.
现在在开这些东西的玩笑。我妻子没能及时关掉NXIVM的纪录片，当时我女儿假装睡着了，然后说，你知道，妈妈，什么是性邪教？我们俩面面相觑，所以，嗯，所以，你知道，无论如何，他们，在某种程度上，揭露这些东西内部发生的事情及其对人们的影响是好的，但它同时也带有一种耸人听闻和“他者化”的色彩，并且伴随着一些其他风险。我是说，一个是某种受害者指责，但另一个是假装说，哦，看看这个奇怪的群体，看看他们做了什么。是的，我觉得当那些电影奏效时，你在说，这是人类行为的常态。
You know, like when I was taught the Holocaust in school, I always felt like frustrated because the way that they were teaching in middle school was like, I think we were in sixth grade. And they were like, yeah, this is this crazy thing people did. They're never going to do this again. We need to learn about it because it's just so weird. And no one will ever do this. And I was like, no, no, no. You know, this is you're telling me that this is an anomaly of human nature. But what I feel is that this is the unchecked nature of empire and impulse and id and that our job is to hold and meet the moving target of managing these realities, not say, well, thank God this happened in Germany in 1940 and will never happen again. That seems like
你知道，就像我在学校学习大屠杀时，我总是感到沮丧，因为他们在中学教书的方式，我想我们当时在六年级。他们说，是的，这是人们做的疯狂的事情。他们永远不会再这样做了。我们需要了解它，因为它太奇怪了。没有人会再这样做。而我当时想，不，不，不。你知道，这是你在告诉我，这是人性的一种反常。但我感觉到的是，这是帝国、冲动和本我未受约束的本质，我们的工作是保持并应对管理这些现实的移动目标，而不是说，好吧，感谢上帝，这发生在1940年的德国，永远不会再发生了。这看起来像是
a silly way to teach history. I mean, part of my goal has always been to basically educate the public about this. So to basically, for one reason, to de-stigmatize cult survivors, because everybody thinks, oh, it's only those stupid, crazy, lazy people who get into cults. And that's absolutely not true. But secondly, to realize that what these groups do is they use basic social psychological techniques. They don't have to give you drugs. They don't have to lock you up and hold you against your will. They just slowly change your mind until you adopt that point of view of the world. So the more we can let people, and especially young people today, know what the red flags are, to know what to look out for, what are the questions to ask, you know, when is the time to turn around and run the
一种愚蠢的教学历史的方式。我是说，我的目标的一部分一直基本上是教育公众了解这一点。所以，基本上，出于一个原因，为了消除对邪教幸存者的污名化，因为每个人都认为，哦，只有那些愚蠢、疯狂、懒惰的人才会加入邪教。这绝对不是真的。但其次，要意识到这些群体所做的是，他们使用基本的社会心理学技术。他们不必给你下药。他们不必把你锁起来，违背你的意愿扣留你。他们只是慢慢地改变你的想法，直到你采纳那种世界观。所以我们越能让人们，尤其是今天的年轻人，知道红旗是什么，知道要注意什么，要问什么问题，你知道，什么时候是转身逃跑的时刻，
other direction. And absolutely, there are documentaries that focus more on the sensational aspect or do what some people call trauma porn. But there are there are also some some good documentaries out there that are very educational and and some film teams that actually have learned over time how to work with survivors. And and because, you know, being a survivor and speaking on film is can be very triggering and so like i always advise these companies like have a mental health fund set up so if somebody gets really triggered you have somebody for them to talk to and don't just you know don't just upset them and let it go so reality tv has been incredibly bad at that and not taking responsibility for the things that it does and its participants who a lot of times they're not even paid um it's not all the kardashians
另一个方向。当然，确实有一些纪录片更关注耸人听闻的方面，或者做一些人们所说的“创伤色情”。但也有一些好的纪录片，它们非常有教育意义，还有一些电影团队实际上随着时间的推移学会了如何与幸存者合作。而且，你知道，作为一名幸存者并在电影中发言可能会非常令人触发，所以我总是建议这些公司，设立一个心理健康基金，这样如果有人真的被触发了，你有人可以让他们交谈，不要只是，你知道，不要只是让他们心烦意乱然后就放任不管。所以现实电视在这一点上非常糟糕，没有为它所做的事情及其参与者承担责任，他们很多时候甚至没有得到报酬，这并不是所有的卡戴珊家族。
and i i think too like the documentary a lot of stuff is like well this documentary is bad because of this decision or this one's good because of this decision but i do feel for the directors when i'm watching certain things where it's like if you can do a greater good by not challenging this person who if you don't play the game a little bit walks out of the room and then you can't make the movie and then nobody knows i mean you're always trying to make ethical compromises because these are people that are difficult and you know ephemerally culpable some of them or you know a lot of the accusations that this person's just coming out because it's convenient to them and now the camera's here and there's more money ephemerally culpable, some of them, or, you know, a lot of the accusations that this person's just coming out because it's convenient to them. And now the camera's here and there's more money on
而且我也认为，纪录片很多东西就像，嗯，这部纪录片因为这个决定而糟糕，或者那部因为那个决定而好，但我确实为导演们感到难过，当我观看某些事情时，就像如果你可以通过不挑战这个人来做更大的好事，如果你不稍微玩一下游戏，他们就会走出房间，然后你就不能拍电影了，然后没人知道。我是说，你总是试图做出道德妥协，因为这些人很难相处，而且你知道，他们中的一些人是短暂可责备的，或者，你知道，很多指控说这个人只是因为方便才出来，现在摄像机在这里，有更多的钱，短暂可责备的，他们中的一些人，或者，你知道，很多指控说这个人只是因为方便才出来。现在摄像机在这里，有更多的钱
this side of it. You don't get paid to do documentaries. I can tell you, I mean, they cannot pay you because it would show bias. So if they fly you. I mean, like some of the people who have NXIVM, being ex-NXIVM members was the next career, which I'm not criticizing i'm just saying you know some people pointed that out um yeah why didn't the director challenge this more and it's like well if if they're not on camera they're not on camera you know you do have to make the guests want to participate right right so i agree well i mean so i mean to going back to the original question like you know the difference in 1970 and somebody handing you a flower and a bed sheet at the airport and now you know yes the
在这一边。你拍纪录片拿不到报酬。我可以告诉你，我是说，他们不能付钱给你，因为这会显示出偏见。所以如果他们让你飞过去。我是说，就像一些NXIVM的人一样，成为前NXIVM成员是下一个职业，我不是在批评，我只是说，你知道，有些人指出了这一点。嗯，是的，为什么导演不更多地挑战这一点？这就像，好吧，如果他们不在镜头前，他们就不在镜头前，你知道，你确实必须让嘉宾想要参与，对吧？对，所以我同意。嗯，我是说，回到最初的问题，就像，你知道，1970年的区别，有人在机场递给你一朵花和一张床单，而现在，你知道，是的，
medium is not the same the groups do not look the same we don't have the same sort of uh projection of whatever the old new age falling apart was. But is there something that is similar or do you feel like it's just history moves forward and this is a totally different time? Well, it's certainly similar in that these groups that, that get created basically use the same techniques that were used back in the seventies. I mean, there's nothing different about that.
媒介是不一样的，群体看起来也不一样。我们没有那种旧的新时代分崩离析的投射。但有什么相似之处吗？还是你觉得历史只是向前发展，这是一个完全不同的时代？嗯，它们当然相似，因为这些被创造出来的群体基本上使用了与七十年代相同的技术。我是说，这方面没有什么不同。
And most of these cult leaders are, are the 70s. I mean, there's nothing different about that. And most of these cult leaders are far from original. I mean, that's why in one of my books, I say it looks like they go to the cookie cutter Messiah school because they all act and do the same things. So that remains the same, of course. And, you know, unfortunately, there will always be con artists. There will always be people who want to take advantage of other people. This goes back to the beginning of time. So it's not like this is ever going to go away. It may change shape a little bit, but there's always power-hungry people. And the trick is not to fall under their sway.
大多数邪教领袖都是70年代的产物。我的意思是，这没什么不同。而且大多数邪教领袖一点也不独特。这就是为什么我在我的一本书里说，他们看起来像是从同一个“饼干模具弥赛亚学校”毕业的，因为他们的行为和做法都如出一辙。当然，这一点始终没变。而且，不幸的是，骗子永远都会存在。总会有人想要占别人的便宜。这种情况从古至今一直存在。所以这并不是说它会消失。它可能会稍微改变一下形式，但渴望权力的人永远存在。关键在于不要受他们的摆布。
And not everybody is aware of what they're doing which is a thing that makes it messier in and out of the cult and the leaders of the cult i mean like you oh i think the leaders know what they're doing absolutely they know what they're doing well absolutely like when when you watch something like heaven's gate you know i feel sorry for them in a way that I don't feel sorry for some other modern cults you know you mean the leaders yeah yes absolutely I don't feel sorry for her I feel Marshall Applewhite yeah I mean she was he she was his cult leader she recruited him he got him into this and he was very vulnerable you know he was a gay man in the South in the 50s. You know, he had a lot of troubling incidents. And she basically swept him up. And, you know, all along the way, I don't know, I think this is in
并不是每个人都意识到自己在做什么，这让邪教内部和外部的情况变得更加混乱。我的意思是，像你……哦，我想领袖们知道自己在做什么，绝对知道。当然，当你观看像“天堂之门”这样的纪录片时，我以一种不针对其他现代邪教的方式对他们感到同情。你是说领袖们？是的，绝对。我不为她感到同情，我指的是马歇尔·阿普尔怀特。是的，她是他的邪教领袖，她招募了他，把他带进了这个圈子，而他当时非常脆弱。你知道，他是一个50年代生活在南方的同性恋男子。他经历过很多令人不安的事情。她基本上把他拉了进去。而且，一直以来，我不知道，我想这在……
one of the documentaries or somewhere, you know, all along the way, she was writing home to her daughter and saying, do the right thing, go to college. You know, it's like, OK, lady, you really believe this. Why wouldn't you go and recruit your daughter? You know, so, you know, there was that kind of two faced on her part. And that's what it was so sad is when she died and you'd see the footage in the car of them just basically being kind of gentle nerds hanging out and not understanding why everyone doesn't like them. And, you know, really because you've decided this person's God and they're gone trying to figure out how to reconnect with that. And he was very troubled. I mean, he, you know, when that happened,
在某部纪录片里或者其他什么地方，你知道，她一直都在给女儿写信，说要走正道，去上大学。这就像是，好吧，女士，你真的相信这一套吗？那你为什么不去招募你的女儿呢？所以，她身上有一种两面性。最令人难过的是，当她去世时，你看到车里的录像，他们基本上就像是一群温和的书呆子，聚在一起，不明白为什么大家都不喜欢他们。真的，因为你已经认定这个人是上帝，而他们走了，你还在试图弄清楚如何与那种感觉重新连接。他当时非常困扰。我的意思是，当那件事发生时，
he was like, I can't do this. I can't do this. And so the followers convinced him, oh yes, you can. And so he, in a sense, he was a bit of a pawn of some of the more fervent followers in that group. And I know I get flack for this all the time, because I do feel sorry for him. I mean, I do believe he was exploited and taken advantage of. On the other hand, they did have a lot of perks. You know, they would leave everybody behind and they would go to Las Vegas and gamble and do all this stuff. How can we be any more
他当时说，我做不到，我做不到。于是追随者们说服他，哦，不，你可以的。所以从某种意义上说，他成了该组织中一些更狂热的追随者的棋子。我知道我总是因此受到抨击，因为我确实同情他。我的意思是，我相信他被剥削和利用了。另一方面，他们确实有很多额外的好处。你知道，他们会抛下所有人，去拉斯维加斯赌博，做各种各样的事情。我们怎么能比这更
Two-Face than that? That's the group I did my dissertation on when I went to grad school. I certainly know tons about it and had worked with families. Yeah. And interestingly, that cult started at the very same time as the political cult that I was in. So, again, it was that 70s environment where people were checking out all kinds of different things. Yeah, the Port Huron Statement launched a couple of interesting directions for a few decades. Well, is there something about, like, politics being more aesthetic now that you think drives that individualized? You can just project it yourself.
两面派呢？这就是我读研究生时写论文研究的那个组织。我当然对它了解很多，也曾与他们的家庭合作过。是的。有趣的是，那个邪教开始的时间和我所在的政治邪教是同一个时期。所以，那确实是70年代的环境，人们在尝试各种不同的东西。是的，《休伦港宣言》在几十年里开启了几个有趣的方向。那么，你认为现在政治变得更具审美化，是否推动了这种个人主义？你可以直接投射你自己。
You don't even need the cult leader. You know, like, I think when you have somebody like a politician, like a Reagan or, you know, a Carter, like they're going up and they're saying things that are political and that like, this is my policy. This is what I will do. You know, they're going to say we're Americans and values and whatever. But I mean, they were saying articulating a vision for the direction of the country. That's what I'm going to do. You can get on board with it or not. And that's going to do. You can get on board with it or not. And that's politics to me. Now you look at someone like Trump who ran and I'm not saying it's bad or good. And I'm not
你甚至不需要邪教领袖。你知道，我认为当你有一个像里根或卡特那样的政治人物时，他们会站出来说一些政治性的东西，比如“这是我的政策，这是我将要做的事”。他们会说我们是美国人，有价值观等等。但我的意思是，他们是在阐述国家发展方向的愿景。这就是我要做的。你可以选择支持或不支持。对我来说，这就是政治。现在你看看像特朗普这样的人，我不是说好坏，我不是
saying that this is my opinion. I'm saying statistically, huge chunks of the young left heard what he said and went and voted for him. And as a guy who most people would say is pretty right wing. And he was using language about Occupy Wall Street movement, you know, very lefty thing. Like, he kind of ran almost like a Rorschach test, where you looked at it, and you saw what you wanted. I mean, one person says, Oh, that guy's gonna lower my taxes. Another person says, he's fighting back against the corporations that I don't like, you know, another person says, like, oh, there's a culture war issue. He wants America
说这是我的观点。我是说从统计学上讲，很大一部分年轻左派听了他所说的话，然后去投票给他。而他是一个大多数人会认为相当右翼的人。他使用的语言涉及“占领华尔街”运动，你知道，那是很左翼的东西。他几乎像是在进行罗夏墨迹测试，你看着他，看到了你想看到的东西。我的意思是，一个人说，哦，那家伙会降低我的税收。另一个人说，他在反抗我不喜欢的公司。还有人说，哦，这是一个文化战争问题，他想让美国
to look like the 50s again. And he didn't say really any of those things. He just kind of said empty aesthetic stuff that was more stylistic. And I think something about that lets the, I don't know, what do you think? I mean, do you see that changing the way that we like engage with religion and advertising and all that sphere? Well, I think that for sure the world is far more complex now. And that's part of what I think helps push people toward these groups or these leaders with the answers. Because as human beings, we all want to have some kind of framework for understanding the world. And most of us want to have some kind of framework for understanding the world. And most of us want to have some kind of purpose or some kind of meaning in our life. So if somebody comes
回到50年代的样子。而他并没有真正说过任何这些话。他只是说了一些空洞的、更具风格化的审美辞藻。我认为这在某种程度上让……我不知道，你怎么看？你认为这改变了我们与宗教、广告以及所有这些领域的互动方式吗？嗯，我认为世界现在肯定复杂多了。我认为这在一定程度上促使人们转向这些组织或这些有答案的领袖。因为作为人类，我们都希望有一种框架来理解世界。我们大多数人都希望在生活中有一种目标或某种意义。所以如果有人
along and they have a message that resonates with you, whatever that might be, like I always say, I never would have joined a meditation cult. I mean, I can't sit still that long, you know, but a political group that said we were going to get rid of racism and sexism and all the isms, you know, that sounded great to me. You know, so it has to be. And I think the fact that sometimes these leaders, the political leaders speak in a way that is vague enough that just about anybody can latch on to it. I think that's what you're speaking to. I think that does happen um it's not really tied to a policy you know like it's not like there's not like a cohesive politics seems to be for lack of a better word less political and then you're currently in the case of trump because he's absolutely an idiot but i don't want to go into that in my opinion could you tell us about the political group you got into i don't
出现，并且他们的信息与你产生了共鸣，无论那是什么，就像我常说的，我永远不会加入一个冥想邪教。我的意思是，我坐不住那么久，你知道，但一个说我们要消除种族主义、性别歧视和所有主义的政治团体，你知道，那对我来说听起来很棒。所以它必须是……而且我认为有时这些政治领袖说话的方式足够模糊，几乎任何人都能抓住它。我想这就是你所说的。我认为这确实发生了。它并没有真正与政策挂钩，你知道，就像没有一种连贯的政治，由于缺乏更好的词，它似乎不那么政治化。在特朗普的案例中，因为他绝对是个白痴，但我不想深入讨论我的观点。你能告诉我们你加入的那个政治团体吗？我不想
want you to repeat your story too much but something to give people some kind of history of how you kind of, because I think you almost have to be, have the capacity to be halfway in one of these things before you understand how they work enough to explain them and treat and help. You know, it's kind of like most people that work in this field have some kind of experience with that. And you've been open about yours.
让你过多重复你的故事，但希望能给人们提供一些背景，说明你是如何……因为我认为你几乎必须具备在这些事情中陷进去一半的能力，才能理解它们是如何运作的，从而去解释、治疗和帮助他人。你知道，在这个领域工作的大多数人都有过某种类似的经历。而你对自己的经历一直很坦诚。
Yeah. So I, you know, I was 30 years old. I had just moved back to the United States after living on an island off the coast of Spain for four years. And sometimes I wish I was still there. And I decided it was time to go back and see what was going on in America. And so I landed in San Francisco and it was just at the end of the Vietnam war. And so people on the left as like I was, you know, we're looking for something else to do, what else to get involved in. And so for me, I, I, you know, I was new in town. I was making new friends. I happened to befriend a bunch of women who were political, and that was interesting to me. And then I got asked to join. First, I was asked to join a study
是的。所以，我当时30岁。我在西班牙海岸外的一个岛上住了四年后，刚搬回美国。有时我希望我还在那里。我决定是时候回去看看美国发生了什么。于是我降落在旧金山，那时正好是越战结束。所以像我这样的左派人士，你知道，正在寻找其他事情做，寻找其他可以参与的事情。对我来说，我刚到城里，正在结交新朋友。我碰巧结识了一群有政治倾向的女性，这对我来说很有趣。然后我被邀请加入。起初，我被邀请加入一个学习
group, which I didn't realize was a front group for this other organization. And I thought, sure, I'll join a study group. I'll meet new people. Was it SDS? No, no, no, it wasn't. The group was, well, the final name was the Democratic Workers' Party. Before that, it was called the Workers' Party for Proletarian Socialism. And I think we decided that was too much of a mouthful. But in the beginning, one of the appeals for a lot of people was that the leader was a woman. There were always men and women in the group, but the fact that the leader and the top leadership were women made a big difference in the 70s because most of the groups on the left were male-dominated. They were very macho. I remember going into some
小组，我当时没意识到那是该组织的一个幌子。我想，当然，我会加入一个学习小组。我会结识新朋友。是SDS吗？不，不，不是。这个组织，嗯，最终的名字是民主工人党。在此之前，它被称为无产阶级社会主义工人党。我想我们觉得那个名字太拗口了。但起初，对很多人来说，吸引力之一在于领袖是一位女性。组织里一直有男人和女人，但领袖和高层领导是女性，这在70年代产生了很大的不同，因为左翼的大多数组织都是男性主导的。他们非常大男子主义。我记得走进某个
office somewhere wanting to volunteer, and they go, oh, yeah, great. The ladies are here. They can make the coffee. And you're like, no, screw you. I'm not here to make the coffee. So the fact that this group was offering a women led organization, you know, that was appealing to me at that time. Right. And when I joined, I absolutely had, didn't have a clue what I was joining. I didn't even know there was a leader when I joined. So, you know, it's part of that slowly slowly slowly you get introduced to more and more and more by the time you realize what the hell's going on it's too late to get out I mean that you know that whole metaphor of the frog in the boiling water you know yes um yeah so I got a lot of sunk cost there too that you've already had some good association with it and you've spent
办公室想做志愿者，他们说，哦，太好了，女士们来了。她们可以去煮咖啡。你会想，不，去你的。我不是来煮咖啡的。所以这个组织提供了一个女性领导的组织，这在当时对我很有吸引力。对。当我加入时，我完全不知道我加入的是什么。我加入时甚至不知道有领袖。所以，这是那种慢慢地、慢慢地，你被介绍得越来越多，当你意识到到底发生了什么时，已经太晚了，无法退出了。我的意思是，你知道那个“温水煮青蛙”的隐喻，你知道，是的，嗯，所以我投入了大量沉没成本，因为你已经和它有了很好的联系，而且你已经花费了
time so I probably can just change the course of the ship instead of leaving right no in the there too, that you've already had some good association with it and you've spent time. So I probably can just change the course of the ship instead of leaving. Right. No, in the beginning, you know, we did do some good work politically in the area. And, you know, so that always helped you kind of rationalize the really crappy stuff that was going on. And, you know, at one point I used to say to myself, well, we're in the tradition of Stalin and at least we haven't killed anyone yet. I mean, that's how I was nationalized. So, you know, all along the way, you do see. Even better than him.
时间，所以我可能只是改变船的方向，而不是离开。对。不，起初，你知道，我们在当地确实做了一些好的政治工作。所以这总是帮助你合理化正在发生的那些糟糕的事情。而且，有一次我对自己说，好吧，我们是在斯大林的传统中，至少我们还没有杀人。我的意思是，我就是这样被洗脑的。所以，一直以来，你确实看到……甚至比他更好。
Yeah. Yeah. So, yeah, so that was it. I was very involved for about 10 years. I was almost 41 when I got out. My brain was fried. I luckily found a really good therapist who helped me. I moved to New York to get away from San Francisco. But it was a very grueling life. I mean, we worked from, you know, five in the morning to one in the
是的。是的。所以，就是这样。我深度参与了大约10年。我出来时快41岁了。我的大脑都烧坏了。幸运的是，我找到了一位非常好的治疗师帮助我。我搬到了纽约，为了远离旧金山。但那是一段非常艰苦的生活。我的意思是，我们从早上五点工作到凌晨一点，
morning, sleep deprived, had no money, ate burritos, and that was about it. And I spent most of our time sitting around in circles criticizing somebody. It was a very, very emotionally and psychologically battering organization. And I was a top leader. I did all of that to others in the group. So when I got out, I had a lot of guilt and shame, and that was difficult. I mean, I was actually suicidal for a long time. I was like, how did I become that person? Like, what the hell? So, I mean, I think that's a lot what people don't understand is sort of once you leave, that's not over.
睡眠不足，没有钱，吃墨西哥卷饼，差不多就是这样。我大部分时间都在围成圈批评别人。这是一个在情感和心理上都非常摧残人的组织。而我曾是一名高层领导。我对组织里的其他人也做了同样的事。所以当我出来时，我感到非常内疚和羞耻，这很困难。我的意思是，我实际上有很长一段时间都有自杀倾向。我在想，我怎么会变成那样的人？到底是怎么回事？所以，我认为人们不理解的是，一旦你离开，那并不是结束。
Then there's a whole other process of recovery that takes time, which is kind of falls into your area well i think that's true um and that like a lot of like i've been in consultation groups or trainings where a therapist has said you know so-and-so left this high control group maybe they didn't use that language but they left this you know religious sect or something and i think i so i would think that they wouldn't have these politics anymore i would think that they wouldn't have this you you know, outlook socially or something. And it's like, that's not how it works. They're just out. Like the base of your brain is still acting on all of these assumptions emotionally that vulnerability is bad. And when someone is being vulnerable, that is their fault because they're not taking, you know, initiative or whatever. Right. I, you know, a lot of therapists listen to this show and they're probably, you know,
然后还有一个漫长的恢复过程，这正好属于你的领域。嗯，我认为这是真的。而且，很多时候，我参加过咨询小组或培训，治疗师会说，某某人离开了这个高控制组织——也许他们没用那个词，但他们离开了这个宗教派别之类的。我想，我会认为他们不再有这些政治观点了，我会认为他们在社交上不会有这种看法了。但事实并非如此。他们只是离开了。你的大脑底层仍然在情感上基于所有这些假设运作，认为脆弱是坏事。当有人表现出脆弱时，那是他们的错，因为他们没有采取主动等等。对。我知道很多治疗师在听这个节目，他们可能，你知道，
you know, trauma therapists. And we know how to deal with trauma when the patient's saying this is trauma, we kind of know how to say, well, maybe you're being manipulated in a relationship or something or by a parent or a friend, but cults are kind of different. I mean, and you correct me where I'm wrong, but the people that I've had who come in who I suspect are in a high control group, or they're telling me, I think maybe I'm an occult. I mean, usually I know that that person
是创伤治疗师。我们知道当病人说这是创伤时该如何处理，我们知道如何说，嗯，也许你在一段关系中被操纵了，或者被父母或朋友操纵了，但邪教有点不同。我的意思是，如果你错了请纠正我，但我接待过那些我怀疑身处高控制组织的人，或者他们告诉我，我想我可能在邪教里。我的意思是，通常我知道那个人
has heard from everyone around them for so long. This person's so bad. He's a pedophile. He did this thing and you can't do that. And he controls you. They already have heard that intellectually, you know, they don't need more of that. I mean, what I open the door with is tell me about the good experiences there and why you're there. because the goal is to teach them that they don't need that group to have that experience. And they've been told you'll never have a father's love. You'll never be understood. You'll never have the opportunity to go to work. So, I mean, that's my approach.
已经从周围所有人那里听了太久了。这个人太坏了。他是恋童癖。他做了这件事，你不能那样做。他控制着你。他们已经在理智上听过这些了，你知道，他们不需要更多这些。我的意思是，我打开话题的方式是，告诉我你在那里的美好经历以及你为什么在那里。因为目标是教导他们，他们不需要那个组织也能拥有那种体验。他们被告知你永远不会得到父亲的爱。你永远不会被理解。你永远不会有机会去工作。所以，这就是我的方法。
But do you have some tips for people who treat someone who may come in with that you know history well i think it's important first of all for therapists to be aware of what might be the presenting symptoms is so to speak in your language i mean a lot of i have a friend who left the uh the cult i was in we were both in the same cult she was also high level um she just contacted me after 35 years. We hadn't talked in 35 years. And she said she went to therapy for about 15 years and she never mentioned the cult because she still felt loyal inside of herself. So she kind of dealt with all these issues around it. And now 35 years later,
但你对那些治疗可能有这种历史的人有什么建议吗？嗯，我认为首先治疗师意识到什么是所谓的“呈现症状”是很重要的。我的意思是，我有一个朋友离开了那个我所在的邪教。我们都在同一个邪教里，她也是高层。她在35年后联系了我。我们已经35年没说话了。她说她接受了大约15年的治疗，但她从未提到过邪教，因为她内心深处仍然感到忠诚。所以她处理了所有围绕它的问题。现在35年后，
she's like exploding with emotion because she's finally realizing what the hell she was in. And so I think being able to assess if that is someone's situation and then to tread very lightly, like you cannot confront. And this is what I tell families all the time. Like the last thing you want to do is confront the person or say, oh, well, that's bad. Get out. That's only going to push them further back in. So I think your approach of saying, oh, well, what was good about it, and why did you leave, and get them to separate that, because there always is some good, otherwise no one would ever be there to begin with. Yeah, I think that nothing that is good in a cult
她情绪爆发了，因为她终于意识到她到底身处什么之中。所以我认为能够评估这是否是某人的情况，然后非常谨慎地行事，你不能对抗。这就是我一直告诉家人的。你最不想做的事就是对抗那个人，或者说，哦，那很糟糕，快出来。那只会把他们推得更远。所以我认为你的方法，问“哦，那有什么好的，你为什么离开”，让他们把这些分开，因为总有一些好的地方，否则一开始就不会有人在那里。是的，我认为邪教中没有任何好的东西
is original to the cult, and so if you can find the thing that's good, you know, there's a lot that's original that's bad, you know, but some you put these you know two eastern words together or something and in fact you know in all the years i've been doing this all the people i've worked with because i get asked all the time well what you know is you know as i was saying earlier is it just stupid people who join or they're so weak or they're so this you don't want a stupid person in a cult they just eat the food man you You get people who are so smart and have not been well understood and they have all this potential. And then you say the way you can actualize that potential is by doing slave labor for me.
是邪教独有的。所以如果你能找到好的东西，你知道，有很多邪教独有的坏东西，但有些你把这两个东方词放在一起之类的。事实上，你知道，在我做这一行的所有年头里，我合作过的所有人，因为我总是被问到，你知道，正如我刚才所说的，是愚蠢的人才会加入吗？或者他们太软弱，或者他们太……你不会想要一个愚蠢的人在邪教里，他们只会吃东西。你会得到那些非常聪明、没有被很好理解、拥有巨大潜力的人。然后你告诉他们，实现这种潜力的方法就是为我做奴隶劳动。
Exactly. That's extravagant. But yeah, the, you know, the thing is that people need to realize, I think that the, if there's any common denominator of who joins cults, it's idealism, right? It's people doing a lot of some wish to have a better life, change the society, find a better religion. You know, it could be even make more money, right? If you want to look at the multiple stuff. And so it's that idealism, it's the goodness in the person. And that's what gets twisted and turned against them. And then they're, they're instilled with this fear. I mean, I was told if I left, I would die in the streets, you know, I would just die in the gutter. No one would want me. I was a dirty ex-communist, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And, you know, and so staying
没错。那太奢侈了。但确实，你知道，人们需要意识到的是，我认为如果说加入邪教的人有什么共同点的话，那就是理想主义，对吧？他们都是怀着让生活变得更好、改变社会、寻找更好宗教的愿望的人。你知道，甚至可能是为了赚更多的钱，对吧？如果你想从多个角度来看的话。所以正是这种理想主义，正是人身上的善良，被扭曲并用来对付他们。然后他们被灌输了这种恐惧。我的意思是，我曾被告知如果我离开，我就会死在街头，你知道，我只会死在阴沟里。没人会要我。我是一个肮脏的前共产主义者，等等等等。而且，你知道，所以留下来
sometimes seems better than the, than the fear of leaving. And, and so staying sometimes seems better than the than the fear of leaving. And and so working. I'm actually going to be starting some courses for therapists that I'll be doing through my nonprofit. Those are great to know. Send me those when you when you get them up and we'll link to them. Yeah, because I've done one before and now I'm kind of regrouping and and hope to do another one again sometime in the spring, because that's one of the hardest things for people who leave is finding a therapist who understands what these after effects are and how to help them. Yeah. Do you have, um, I don't know how much you overlap with therapy in your professional or personal life, but you find that there's a style of therapy that is more helpful or a, you know, better. Yeah. Well, I'm not a therapist, first of all, but what I,
有时看起来比离开的恐惧要好。所以留下来有时看起来比离开的恐惧要好。所以我正在努力。我实际上要通过我的非营利组织为治疗师开设一些课程。这些信息很有用。当你准备好后发给我，我们会附上链接。是的，因为我以前做过一个，现在我正在重新整合，希望在春天的某个时候再做一次，因为对于离开的人来说，最困难的事情之一就是找到一个了解这些后遗症以及如何帮助他们的治疗师。是的。你在职业或个人生活中与心理治疗的重叠程度如何，我不知道，但你是否发现某种风格的治疗更有帮助，或者说更好？嗯，首先，我不是治疗师，但我
what I advise for one is not, at least not immediately using EMDR. EMDR is kind of a fad right now. It a bit of a rage but with with culture dying out i think i think it's evolved into something that works a little bit better and especially if someone's been in any kind of meditation cult or a cult where they went into trance states a lot like emdr is just going to trigger the crap out of them so because they're very likely to be dissociative right what you're doing is uncorking a dissociative disorder and in complex trauma, which is where EMDR really messes people up. I mean, you hear the horror story where the person is going to, because I was an EMDR therapist for years, and the EMDR people don't do themselves favors in that they don't admit where it works and
我建议的一点是，至少不要立即使用EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工疗法）。EMDR现在有点像一种时尚。它非常流行，但随着邪教的消亡，我认为它已经演变成一种效果稍好的东西，特别是如果某人曾身处某种冥想邪教或经常进入恍惚状态的邪教中，EMDR只会让他们产生极大的触发反应，因为他们很可能具有解离倾向。所以你所做的是打开了一个解离性障碍和复杂性创伤的潘多拉魔盒，这正是EMDR真正让人们陷入困境的地方。我的意思是，你听过那些恐怖故事，因为我做了多年的EMDR治疗师，而EMDR从业者并没有帮到自己，因为他们不承认它在哪些方面有效，以及
why it works. And it does work for some things. Right. So that's one caution I would make. And also, I mean, the ones that people have told me have been helpful were IFS. That's been helpful to people to some degree. Frankly, just good old talk therapy. I mean, people just need to talk it out. They need to kind of debrief.
为什么它有效。它确实对某些事情有效。对，所以这是一个我会提出的警告。而且，我的意思是，人们告诉我很有帮助的是IFS（内在家庭系统疗法）。这对人们在一定程度上是有帮助的。坦率地说，就是老式的谈话疗法。我的意思是，人们只需要说出来。他们需要进行某种汇报。
Yeah. I would think an overly behavioral therapy or a more cognitive therapy wouldn't work because the person's goals are not really what they need. Something that was more emotion-focused or parts driven like IFS, any of the post-yungi and stuff would maybe help them contain the experience. Yeah. And you don't want to tell them what to do like oh go you know go now and do this and like don't know they've been told what to do too many times so you know it's um but you know it's hard to find good therapists so a lot you know i mean that's why i wrote my book take back your life and i hope therapists are who think they may have that kind of clientele would read the book. I always tell survivors, like if you go to a therapist, well, first of all, I have a checklist on my website, like how to find a good therapist. Like what are the kinds of questions to ask?
是的。我认为过于行为导向的疗法或认知疗法可能不会奏效，因为当事人的目标并不是他们真正需要的。更注重情感或基于部分（parts-driven）的疗法，比如IFS，或者任何后荣格学派的东西，也许能帮助他们容纳这种体验。是的。而且你不想告诉他们该做什么，比如“哦，去吧，现在去做这个”，不，他们已经被告知太多次该做什么了，所以你知道，这很难找到好的治疗师，所以这就是我写《夺回你的生活》（Take Back Your Life）这本书的原因，我希望那些认为自己可能有这类客户的治疗师能读读这本书。我总是告诉幸存者，如果你去看治疗师，首先，我的网站上有一个清单，关于如何找到好的治疗师。比如应该问什么样的问题？
And I try to impress upon them like you're hiring that person, that person's working for you. And if you, you know, don't be bossed around. If you want to leave, don't tell them, Oh no, you can't leave all of that. But I think it's important to be able to find out is that therapist using any kind of gimmicks or new agey bullshit you know it's like that's not gonna help you know yeah the maybe um and i think i've heard of some styles of therapy saying kind of culty stuff to patients who called and said this was my experience It's like well, what do they say? You know if your therapist says something like well, I won't talk to that part of you
我试图让他们明白，你是雇主，那个人是在为你工作。如果你，你知道，不要被指使。如果你想离开，不要听他们说“哦不，你不能离开”之类的。但我认为能够查明该治疗师是否在使用任何噱头或新时代的胡言乱语是很重要的，你知道，那对你没有帮助。是的，也许，而且我想我听说过一些治疗风格对那些打电话说“这是我的经历”的病人说了一些类似邪教的话。那是怎么说的？你知道，如果你的治疗师说类似“嗯，我不会和你那部分对话”
That's your trauma or something. That seems strange, you know, some of this stuff is lifted right from those documentaries Well, of course either there are plenty of therapy cults, you know cult therapists who are their own little cult around them I can't tell you how many people have come to me about that. So, yeah. Is it rebirthing is one of the big ones or, you know, some of the, I haven't ever heard you talk about what's his name. Who's the Canadian that did Michelle remembers, Satanic Panic. Oh, yeah, yeah. You know, for a while I was, I was a colleague with Dr. Margaret Singer, who was a clinical psychologist at Berkeley. And she was kind of the preeminent cult expert at that time. And we wrote two books together.
“那是你的创伤”之类的话。这看起来很奇怪，你知道，其中一些东西直接摘自那些纪录片。当然，有很多治疗邪教，你知道，邪教治疗师围绕着他们形成自己的小邪教。我无法告诉你有多少人因为这个来找我。所以，是的。重生疗法（rebirthing）是其中之一，或者，你知道，一些，我从来没听你谈过那个叫什么名字的人。那个制作了《米歇尔的回忆》（Michelle Remembers）和撒旦恐慌（Satanic Panic）的加拿大人是谁？哦，是的，是的。你知道，有一段时间，我是玛格丽特·辛格博士（Dr. Margaret Singer）的同事，她是伯克利的一位临床心理学家。她是当时最杰出的邪教专家。我们一起写了两本书。
And one of them is called Crazy Therapies. I haven't read it. You've read it? Yeah. I love that. I'm trying to figure out how to make sure it doesn't go out of print. So I'm actually working with her son to try to contact the publishers and see what we can do about both of the books that we did together to make sure they stay in print. Cause they're really valuable. I mean, some of these,
其中一本叫《疯狂的疗法》（Crazy Therapies）。我没读过。你读过？是的。我很喜欢。我正在想办法确保它不会绝版。所以我正在和她的儿子合作，试图联系出版商，看看我们能为我们一起写的两本书做些什么，以确保它们保持印刷。因为它们非常有价值。我的意思是，其中一些，
maybe a second draft, there's been some crazy therapy since then. It kind of needs to be updated. Like, you know, when we wrote that, one of the big phrases was UFO therapy, right? And I don't think that's so much of a thing right now anymore. I mean, UFOs were kind of a thing. You see it coming back, like Chris Bledsoe's book and some other things, because a lot of people, some people have an experience. I don't know what it is. You want to conceptualize it in a mystical way or whatever i'm not telling you i'm going to fight with you about i don't know how the universe works but what happens is that there's a lot of people who i
也许需要第二版，从那以后出现了一些疯狂的疗法。它确实需要更新。就像，你知道，当我们写那本书时，其中一个大词是“UFO疗法”，对吧？我不认为现在还有那么多这种东西了。我的意思是，UFO曾经是一回事。你看到它又回来了，比如克里斯·布莱索（Chris Bledsoe）的书和其他一些东西，因为很多人，有些人确实有某种经历。我不知道那是什么。你想以一种神秘的方式来概念化它，或者随便你怎么说，我不会和你争论，我不知道宇宙是如何运作的，但发生的事情是，有很多人，我
think have had a traumatic incident like sexual abuse and it is easier to kind of subconsciously say well you know the alien did this than it is to really admit reality and heal. And when the therapist is playing into that and not helping you weigh things, that is very dangerous because the therapist believes in UFOs and might be doing the same thing, but they're traumatic experience. Right. Right. That's where I see the therapy modalities become called. So it's where a therapist says this worked for me. It worked for everybody. And, and, and you have to do this to get better.
我认为他们经历过创伤性事件，比如性虐待，潜意识里说“嗯，你知道，是外星人干的”比真正承认现实并治愈要容易得多。当治疗师顺应这一点而不帮助你权衡事情时，这是非常危险的，因为治疗师相信UFO，可能也在做同样的事情，但他们是创伤性经历。对。对。这就是我看到治疗模式变成邪教的地方。也就是当治疗师说“这对我有效。它对每个人都有效。你必须这样做才能好起来。”
And if you don't do that this way, you're doing it wrong. I'm kind of like, I don't know how to get better. What do you think we should try? There's this approach. You like that on this one? Exactly. Exactly. Yeah. Did you, did you ever write about the rebirthing called other than that, or the psychotherapy called other than in your book the 50 crazy other than in crazy therapies um no i haven't written anything
“如果你不这样做，你就做错了。”我有点像，我不知道怎么好起来。你觉得我们应该尝试什么？有这种方法。你喜欢这个吗？完全正确。完全正确。是的。你有没有写过关于重生邪教的内容，除了在你的书《50种疯狂疗法》之外？嗯，没有，我没有写过任何
else about that i mean i've in the i've had clients who went through that experience i have certainly haven't recently um is that still a thing no one's pretty gone. There may be some unlicensed people that kind of do something in the high hills. But usually the phases of therapy, like therapy, when it comes out, like the problem is that there are academic cults, too, because there's a lot of insecurity in academia and you get a lot of people especially in soft sciences where they're like extremely hostile to this new anything new and they don't and so they'll they'll take you know they'll be like well we can't quite turn this totally empirical or there haven't been 15 randomized controlled trials randomized controlled trials on it yet so it's complete bs it's not, which is too reactionary. And then you have private practice, which tends to move to what patients want quicker. And so
关于那个的其他东西。我的意思是，我曾有过经历过那种体验的客户，我当然最近没有。那现在还有吗？基本消失了。可能有一些无证人员在山上做些什么。但通常治疗的阶段，当它出现时，问题在于也有学术邪教，因为学术界有很多不安全感，你会得到很多人，特别是在软科学领域，他们对任何新事物都极其敌视，所以他们会，你知道，他们会说“嗯，我们不能完全将其经验化”或者“还没有进行过15次随机对照试验”，所以这是完全的胡说八道，这太反动了。然后你有私人诊所，往往会更快地转向病人想要的东西。所以
there, there's sort of cults in there where there's tension between them. I think EMDR is one of the best examples because it works miracles. If you look at the research, like it works miracles for like 25, 30% of people, certain conditions conditions dissociation is not when you want to use it for complex btsc is not when you want to use it for um and it does nothing for about 70 75 percent of people so everybody who got better that way was like this is a miracle and they're chasing that experience and they're wanting that spiritual experience with the patient they're not noticing that everyone else is leaving first or second session and then you have researchers that are like that is complete crystal healing woo-woo nonsense there's nothing about it there is a neurological thing happening so we didn't
那里，存在某种邪教，它们之间存在张力。我认为EMDR是最好的例子之一，因为它创造了奇迹。如果你看研究，它对25%到30%的人创造了奇迹，某些条件下的解离并不是你想用它的时候，复杂性PTSD也不是你想用它的时候，而且它对大约70%到75%的人没有任何作用。所以每个通过那种方式好起来的人都觉得“这是一个奇迹”，他们正在追逐那种体验，他们正在与病人寻求那种精神体验，他们没有注意到其他人第一或第二次治疗就离开了。然后你有研究人员说“那是完全的水晶疗法胡说八道”，它没有任何依据，有一个神经学上的东西在发生，所以我们没有
understand what it was well something like brain spotting is way more generalizable it's way more safe i don't think it's the end of where that kind of medicine's going but you you needed EMDR to get to that one and when you have such hostility in academia like it makes new models of therapy act like cults even when they're good which I don't think is good and when I did like emotional transformation therapy with Stephen Vasquez which if I hadn't read the research and if I hadn't been to the training and felt like I wouldn't believe it worked but I was making that joke and he didn't think it was funny and I said he was't think it was funny. And I said, he was like, well, it's not a cult. We prefer to think of it like a family.
理解它是什么。嗯，像“大脑定位”（brain spotting）这样的东西更具普遍性，更安全。我不认为那是那种医学发展的终点，但你需要EMDR才能达到那个阶段。当学术界有如此大的敌意时，它使得新的治疗模式表现得像邪教，即使它们是好的，我认为这并不好。当我做斯蒂芬·瓦斯奎兹（Stephen Vasquez）的情绪转化疗法（ETT）时，如果我没有读过研究，如果我没有参加过培训并感觉到它，我不会相信它有效。但我开了那个玩笑，他觉得不好笑，我说他觉得不好笑。我说，他就像，“嗯，这不是邪教。我们更愿意把它看作一个家庭。”
And I was like, oh, you already know your lines. And like, he didn't think that was funny at all. Cause he's a nice guy and it's not a cult, but it looks very weird from the outside. And there's a lot of new models that are kind of like that. Well, in fact, I mean, when we wrote Crazy Therapies, which I think was in 94, 95, I mean, we trashed EMDR. I mean, there's a chapter on it, but it was brand new. And it was like, oh, this woman walked in the woods and had a revelation. It's like, oh, I've heard that before. I don't disagree with you though. I use EMDR where it works, but I don't disagree with the research's take on it. I disagree with the meta analysis that say there's nothing to this. Everyone doing it's crazy.
我说，“哦，你已经知道你的台词了。”他一点也不觉得好笑。因为他是个好人，它不是邪教，但从外面看非常奇怪。有很多新的模式有点像那样。事实上，我的意思是，当我们写《疯狂的疗法》时，我想是在94、95年，我们抨击了EMDR。我的意思是，有一章是关于它的，但它是全新的。就像，“哦，这个女人走进树林，得到了启示。”就像，“哦，我以前听过那个。”不过我并不反对你。我在它有效的地方使用EMDR，但我并不反对研究对它的看法。我反对那些说“这毫无意义，所有做它的人都是疯子”的荟萃分析。
Right. Yeah. So, okay. We can agree on that. Primal scream therapy. You had primal scream in there too, didn't you? Yeah. I'm sure we had primal scream. I got primal scream. Yeah. That's another one. Oh, I don't know, man. And I think when the, when the industry moves so cognitive and behavioral so quickly in the eighties, because healthcare got so corporatized and academia largely started to get more corporatized and less state funded, less publicly funded,
对。是的。所以，好吧。我们可以同意这一点。尖叫疗法（Primal scream therapy）。你那里也有尖叫疗法，对吧？是的。我肯定我们有尖叫疗法。我有尖叫疗法。是的。那是另一个。哦，我不知道，伙计。我认为当行业在八十年代如此迅速地转向认知和行为疗法时，因为医疗保健变得如此企业化，学术界在很大程度上开始变得更加企业化，减少了国家资助，减少了公共资助，
it made anyone who was kind of in the middle of, I'm going to just do cognitive behavioral therapy and i want to do some kind of depth-oriented woo-woo a little bit out there whatever it split those worlds apart you know pretty quickly and you had a lot of people that got real weird uh and a lot of people that got real cognitive in the hospital that what do you see is like the biggest way to sort of help you look at things like twin flames which looks so low like low rent compared to i mean keith renier really like he was a lazy guy but he had to work harder than you know something like twin flames university
它使得任何处于中间地带的人——“我只是要做认知行为疗法，我想做一点深度导向的胡说八道”——无论如何，它很快就把这些世界分开了。你知道，你有很多变得非常奇怪的人，还有很多在医院里变得非常认知导向的人。你认为帮助你看待像“双生火焰”（Twin Flames）这类事情的最大方式是什么？它看起来比——我的意思是，基思·拉尼尔（Keith Raniere）真的，他是一个懒惰的人，但他必须比像“双生火焰大学”
or cult of the mother god you know oh god cult of the mother god, you know. Oh, God, Cult of the Mother God. Oh, that documentary. That was one of the most difficult documentaries about cults that I've ever watched. That was heartbreaking. It was pitiful. And I feel like it was really, really negligent of the filmmakers that they didn't have any commentary.
或“上帝之母邪教”（Cult of the Mother God）之类的东西更努力。哦，上帝，上帝之母邪教，你知道。哦，上帝，上帝之母邪教。哦，那部纪录片。那是我看过的关于邪教的最困难的纪录片之一。那令人心碎。那很可怜。我觉得电影制作人没有发表任何评论，这真的很不负责任。
I mean, they basically took the footage that these believers gave them and it was like an ad for mother God with no comment whatsoever and and It was just tragic and that these people are still believers as far as I know and there's you know That was that's a sad one. Oh boy Well, you see things like that that are definitely enabled from the internet existing, definitely enabled by limitations and ability to afford health care, and definitely enabled by everything kind of being an influencer MLM racket now. Right. What does that, where does that go? I mean, NXIVM was not that long ago and I don't think you could do another NXIVM today. I don't think corporate seminars are the path to success. I think it does look more like Twin Flames or Cult of the Mother God. It's this kind of internet, social media thing. How do we protect ourselves, our kids, our, you know, healthcare from that. Well, again, I think it's trying to be aware of the red flags. It's trying to be, you know, ask critical questions. I mean, I always say to people, if you ask a
我的意思是，他们基本上采用了这些信徒给他们的镜头，这就像是上帝之母的广告，没有任何评论，而且这简直是悲剧，据我所知，这些人仍然是信徒，而且你知道，那是一个悲伤的例子。哦，天哪。好吧，你看到像那样的事情，绝对是由互联网的存在所促成的，绝对是由负担不起医疗保健的限制所促成的，也绝对是由现在一切都变成网红传销骗局所促成的。对。那会走向何方？我的意思是，NXIVM（邪教组织）并不是很久以前的事，我不认为你今天还能再搞一个NXIVM。我不认为企业研讨会是成功的途径。我认为它看起来更像“双生火焰”或“上帝之母邪教”。这是一种互联网、社交媒体的东西。我们如何保护我们自己、我们的孩子、我们的医疗保健免受这种影响？嗯，再次，我认为是尝试意识到危险信号。尝试，你知道，提出批判性问题。我的意思是，我总是对人们说，如果你问一个
question and they don't answer it, they turn it back on you. That's a bad sign. Like if you say, well, what about blah, blah, blah. And they say, oh, just take one more course. And then you'll under, you know, then you then ask us the question. Well, you take one more course and then you'll under, you know, then you, then ask us the question. Well, you take one more course and you can't remember the question anymore. Right. And so anytime there's that duplicity, you know, and also I think people move way too fast. Like, you know, you don't buy the first car you look at. So don't jump into the first, whatever spiritual call, whatever kind of group it is like, take your time and investigate. And one of the advantages today of the internet is that there's so much information out there. There's bound to be people who left that group who will be talking about their experiences.
问题，他们不回答，反而把它转嫁给你。这是一个坏迹象。比如你说，“嗯，关于某某某怎么看？”他们说，“哦，再上一门课。然后你就会明白，（然后你再问我们问题）。”好吧，你再上一门课，然后你就不记得那个问题了。对。所以任何时候有这种两面性，你知道，而且我也认为人们行动太快了。就像，你知道，你不会买你看到的第一辆车。所以不要跳进第一个，无论是什么精神邪教，无论是什么样的团体，花点时间调查一下。今天互联网的一个优势是，那里有太多的信息。肯定会有离开那个团体的人在谈论他们的经历。
And so you'll, you know, it's like when you buy a car, you check the blue book or whatever that thing is called, you drive around a few cars, you know, you take your time. So people need to do the same thing when they're thinking about making that kind of personal commitment. Because like you said, then there's the sunk cost. Once you're in, once you've spent thousands of dollars, once you've given up all your friends and your family on the outside, this has become your whole reality. It's going to be just that much harder to leave. So, I mean, it took me five years to leave my group. I wanted to leave for five years and I couldn't do it. I mean, the door was there. I could not walk out the door. I was terrified and I had nothing. I had no resources. I had no money. I had a car that wouldn't make it over
所以你，你知道，就像你买车时，你查蓝皮书或不管那叫什么，你试驾几辆车，你知道，你花点时间。所以人们在考虑做出那种个人承诺时也需要做同样的事情。因为就像你说的，然后是沉没成本。一旦你进去了，一旦你花了数千美元，一旦你放弃了外面所有的朋友和家人，这已经成为你的全部现实。离开它会变得更加困难。所以，我的意思是，我花了五年时间才离开我的团体。我想离开五年，但我做不到。我的意思是，门就在那里。我无法走出那扇门。我很害怕，我一无所有。我没有资源。我没有钱。我有一辆无法开过
the Bay bridge. I mean, it was like, and then they told me I was going to die in the street. So, you know, you just become immobilized. Well, and keeping you in poverty or keeping you in addiction or keeping you in addiction or keeping you in emotional enmeshment or ideally as many as i can do is the point you know then that way you get to pretend there is freedom by saying there's the door if anyone doesn't like it walk out it y'all staying here is supporting me by omission you know right and the twin flames i don't know i mean you know the the documentary escapingcaping Twin Flames on Netflix. I mean, if people haven't seen it, they should.
海湾大桥的车。我的意思是，就像，然后他们告诉我我会死在街头。所以，你知道，你只是变得瘫痪了。嗯，让你陷入贫困，或者让你陷入成瘾，或者让你陷入情感纠缠，或者尽可能多地让我做，这就是重点，你知道，那样你就可以通过说“门在那里，如果不喜欢就走出去”来假装有自由。你们所有人留在这里都是在通过不作为来支持我，你知道，对吧？还有双生火焰，我不知道，我的意思是，你知道，Netflix上的纪录片《逃离双生火焰》（Escaping Twin Flames）。我的意思是，如果人们没看过，他们应该看。
Because this guy, it's so obvious. I mean, he says right there, oh, look at my Porsche. Look at my this. Bring me more money so I can, you know, he's just bought this incredible house in this little town in Michigan. I mean, he is just, in my opinion, such a con artist. I mean, just bamboozling these young women, you know, and it's just tragic. And this young woman, Keely, who's featured in the documentary, you know, when she finally got out, she was so in debt, you know, and she had nobody. She had nothing.
因为这家伙，这太明显了。我的意思是，他就在那里说，“哦，看我的保时捷。看我的这个。”给我更多的钱，这样我可以，你知道，他刚刚在密歇根州这个小镇买了这栋令人难以置信的房子。我的意思是，在我看来，他就是一个骗子。我的意思是，只是在欺骗这些年轻女性，你知道，这简直是悲剧。而纪录片中提到的这个年轻女性基利（Keely），你知道，当她最终出来时，她负债累累，你知道，她一无所有。她什么都没有。
She had recruited her sister and she felt so guilty about having done that. And, you know, and now the group is even worse, you know, they're coercing people into these sex changes. And so young women cutting off their breasts, they're having bottom surgery. They're growing those beards. People that are saying I'm not transgender. I don't want to be, I don't want to change. He's telling them that they have to. These are people who never in their lives dreamed of becoming the
她招募了她的妹妹，她对自己这样做感到非常内疚。而且，你知道，现在这个团体更糟了，你知道，他们强迫人们进行变性。所以年轻女性切除乳房，她们在做下体手术。她们在长胡子。人们说“我不是跨性别者。我不想成为，我不想改变。”他在告诉她们必须这样做。这些人从未梦想过成为
other gender and so it's just tragic because once you do that you can't you know your breasts aren't going to grow back you know once you do it it's done and the fact that they're getting away with that is just criminal in my opinion well the energy around it was so strange because he doesn't try and hide the wealth he doesn't try and hide the agenda he doesn't try and hide the wealth. He doesn't try and hide the agenda. He doesn't try and feign wisdom. I mean, he really, he reminded me of like one of those guys.
另一种性别，所以这简直是悲剧，因为一旦你那样做了，你就不能，你知道，你的乳房不会长回来，你知道，一旦你做了，就完成了。在我看来，他们能逃脱惩罚简直是犯罪。嗯，围绕它的能量太奇怪了，因为他不试图隐藏财富，他不试图隐藏议程，他不试图隐藏财富。他不试图隐藏议程。他不试图假装智慧。我的意思是，他真的，他让我想起了那些家伙中的一个。
Go ahead. He couldn't feign wisdom if he wanted to. Well, like when I was in college, there were all these like Ron Paul, like libertarians that had that kind of long hair and would take mushrooms and play ultimate Frisbee. And it was like like they were just like one joint away from realizing that they were god kind of you know and that is the energy of that guy you know that he's just like
继续。如果他想假装智慧，他也做不到。嗯，就像我在大学时，有所有这些像罗恩·保罗（Ron Paul）那样的自由意志主义者，留着那种长发，会吃蘑菇，玩极限飞盘。就像他们离意识到自己是上帝只差一个关节，你知道，那种能量就是那个家伙的能量，你知道，他就像
when he's revealing it it's like you know what it's gonna be and he has this kind of stupid slimy grin and he's like guys i figured something out actually i'm Jesus. And it's just so like, who is falling for this? Yeah. And I think if people watch the documentary, it's only three episodes and it's all original footage that they have, but you see him sort of getting meaner and meaner and more angry and yelling at him. Seeing what he can get away with. Yeah. And that's what cult leaders do. Like the more they can get away with, the more they'll push the envelope and keep at that. And so, I mean, that was so obvious in the documentary, but the real concern is that baby, you know, they had a baby and baby grace. And he says right there, you know, he says, baby grace is only going to have sex with
当他揭露它时，就像你知道它会是什么，他有这种愚蠢的黏糊糊的笑容，他说，“伙计们，我发现了一些东西，其实我是耶稣。”这简直是，谁会相信这个？是的。而且我认为如果人们看那部纪录片，只有三集，而且都是他们拥有的原始镜头，但你看到他变得越来越刻薄，越来越愤怒，对他们大喊大叫。看看他能逃脱什么。是的。这就是邪教领袖所做的。他们能逃脱的越多，他们就会越得寸进尺，并坚持下去。所以，我的意思是，这在纪录片中太明显了，但真正的担忧是那个婴儿，你知道，他们有一个婴儿，格蕾丝宝宝（Baby Grace）。他就在那里说，你知道，他说，“格蕾丝宝宝只会和上帝发生性关系”，而他就是上帝，他相信他是上帝。所以这对那个婴儿的未来意味着什么？我的意思是，对我来说，这是最大的担忧之一。嗯，他们不是告诉每个人他们要买这块地，并希望他们搬到那里去建立公社吗？那还在计划中吗？我刚去过那里。我刚在密歇根州的特拉弗斯城（Traverse City），那是隔壁的城镇。他们带了基利和我，我们为国家作家系列（National Writer Series）举办了这个大型活动。那个城镇现在准备好对抗这个团体了，因为他们说已经有30个人搬到那里了。现在他想说这个，这是有记录的。
God and he's God, he believes he's God. So what does that say about the future of that baby? I mean, that to me is one of the biggest concerns. Well, and didn't they tell everyone that they were going to buy this land and they wanted them to move there to have a commune? Is that still on the books? I was just there. I was just in Traverse City, Michigan, which is the town right next door. They brought Keely and I, and we did this big event for the National Writer Series. And that town is now ready to roll against this group because they're saying they there's already 30 people who have moved there. And now he's wanting to said this it's recorded.
他想买一大块地，让每个人都搬到那里。他们现在已经注册为教会了。他就在那里说，他这样做是为了不用付钱给人们，你知道，他会得到税收减免。所以他没有打算，你知道，关闭或停止或放慢速度。而且，你知道，人们为那些课程支付数千美元。
He wants to buy a big plot of land and have everybody move there. They've now registered as a church. And he says right there, he's doing it so that he doesn't have to pay people, you know, and he'll get the tax write-off. And so he has no intention of, you know, shutting down or closing or slowing down. And, you know, people pay thousands for those courses.
他们在世界各地有50,000名追随者。50,000。所以即使其中十分之一搬到那个城镇，那是一个可爱的小镇，萨顿斯湾（Sutton's Bay），那将会是，你知道。就像罗杰尼希（Rajneesh）的追随者一样，你知道，你会有社区对抗。是的，那是他的梦想。所以希望在这一切发生之前能发生一些事情。是的，嗯，这是可怕的，可怕的事情。你看到，嗯，某个地方，你的学术，是的，我的意思是，这些事情已经发生
They have 50,000 followers around the world. 50,000. So even if a tenth of those move to that town, which is an adorable little town, Sutton's Bay, it's going to be, you know. It's like the Rajneesh's, you know, you're going to have the community versus. Yeah, that's his dream. So hopefully things can happen before that takes place yeah well it's scary scary stuff and do you see um somewhere did your did your academic yeah i mean these things have gone
了自青铜时代以来，下一代会是什么，我们如何为它做准备？但你知道，你看到你的学术重点，你知道，随着你的工作过程而改变吗？还是你觉得你只是在做同样的事情，试图弄清楚明天会是什么样子？是的，我的意思是，你知道，事情已经进步了，就像我刚才说的，比如理解基于互联网的邪教等等。是的，它，你知道，我的意思是，有时我得到，我确实做了很多专家证人工作，这真的很有趣，因为当我在处理这样的案件时，为了写我的报告，我必须真正深入挖掘一些东西。所以，我喜欢做这些，因为我觉得至少我们得到了一些正义，对吧？我们让某人拿回了他们的钱，或者我们让某人进了监狱，等等。
on since the bronze age it'll be what is the next generation and how do we prepare for it but you know do you see your academic focus you know changing over the course of of your you know work with this or do you kind of feel like you're just doing the same thing trying to figure out what it's going to look like tomorrow yeah i mean you know things have advanced like i was saying earlier like understanding the internet-based cults and things like that. Yeah, it's, you know, I mean, sometimes I get, I do do a lot of expert witness work, and that's really interesting, because I get to really dig deep into something when I'm working on a case like that in order to write my report. So, and I enjoy doing those, because I feel like at least we're getting some justice, right? We're getting someone their money back, or we're getting someone put in prison, whatever.
所以重要的事情，我认为，是人们，如果他们要离开，要考虑他们能带走什么有犯罪证据的东西。我的意思是，一旦你有犯罪证据，而且几乎所有这些团体都犯有某种罪行。然后他们变得懒惰，因为他们已经得寸进尺太远了。对，他们自以为是。但当你有人口贩运或性贩运时，那是联邦罪行。所以这就是我们如何扳倒拉尼尔（Ranieri）的。现在还有几个针对这个墨西哥教会领袖的案件，实际上是全球性的。但那里的领袖，三代领袖，祖父，父亲，现在是儿子。
So the important thing, I think, is for people to, if they're going to leave, to think about what they can take with them that has evidence of the crimes. I mean, once you have evidence of the crimes, and almost all of these groups commit some crime or other. And then they get lazy because they've pushed the envelope so far. Right, they're full of themselves. But when you have labor trafficking or sex trafficking, those are federal crimes. And so that's how we brought Ranieri down. There's a couple of other cases now happening against the leader of this Mexican church, which actually is worldwide. But the leader there was for three generations of leaders, the grandfather, the father, now the son.
他们称自己为使徒，他们诱导女性，让她们的九岁女孩被送进卧室陪他。这已经持续了几十年了。那个家伙因为一个非常小的刑期在监狱里，但还有五起针对他的诉讼。所以收集证据非常重要，但是，对不起。是的。我相信我会一直做这个，直到我躺在临终床上，那可能很快就会到来。我希望不会。嗯，如果你有兴趣解决你的一些存在主义恐惧，我有一份关于这个组织的小册子。是的，我可以和你谈谈我的来世。我想你已经和法院和受害者做了足够多的工作
They call themselves the apostle and they groom the women to send their nine-year-old girls are sent into the bedroom with him. And this has been going on for decades. That guy is in prison on a very small sentence, but there's five more lawsuits against him. So gathering evidence is really important, but excuse me. Yeah. I'm sure I'll be doing this till I'm on my deathbed, which may be soon. I hope not. Well, I have a brochure about this organization if you're interested in addressing some of your existential fears. Yeah, I can talk to you about my afterlife. I think you've done enough work with courts and with victims
你可能已经见过了。但就像你说的，你从来没有加入过冥想邪教，但你确实有这种理想主义。我想被赋予最政治化的工具来做最大的好事。你们在这里谈论的是最好的游戏。在我看来，无论你的阴影是什么，无论你在逃避什么，无论你无法停止重温的创伤性经历，或者你不知道如何处理小时候的事情，或者你知道，你想要避免的情绪，你知道，无论我试图抛出几种不同的治疗模型语言，以便人们能够识别他们的风格。但这正是这些人的接近方式以及你容易受到什么影响的原因。而且，NXIVM是一件有趣的事情，因为他们中没有
that you've probably seen it. But like you said, you'd never joined a meditation cult, but you did have this kind of idealistic. I want to be given the most political tools to do the most good. And y'all are talking the best game here. It seems to me like whatever your shadow is, whatever you're running from, whatever the traumatic experience that you, you know, you can't quit reliving, but also don't know how to deal with from being a kid or that, you know, the emotion that you want to avoid, you know, whatever I'm trying to throw out a couple of different therapeutic models of language there so that people can recognize their style. But that is what informs how these people approach you and what you're susceptible for. And, and, and NXxium was an interesting thing and that none of those
人想法相同，他也没有以类似的方式与他们中的任何一个人交谈，你知道，对有些人，他会去找他们说“我是魔术师巫师，我的精液实际上发出蓝光，是魔法”，字面上他说了那个，我不是在编造。然后对其他人，他就像“我是科学家，这是合乎逻辑的，你来自一个神秘的邪教，但我们要把它申请专利，因为我的想法太聪明了，它实际上是技术”之类的，你知道，嗯，而且你看到，嗯，这个人从未得到父母的关注，无法让他们的想法被看到，然后这个人如果他们有某种骗子原型能量，他们想要能够去煽动，你知道，像邦德·谢拉（Bond on Sheila）那样的人，他能够得到，而且一些家伙
people thought the same and he didn't talk to any of them similarly you know to some people he was going to them and saying i'm a magician wizard and my semen actually glows blue and is magic literally he said that i'm not making it and then to other people he was like i'm a scientist this is logical you're coming from a mystical cult but we're gonna get this patented because my idea is so brain smart it's actually technology or something you know um and and you see well this person never was given attention from parents to be to have their ideas seen and then this person is really if they have kind of a trickster archetype energy they want to be able to go rabble rouse you know a bond on sheila type person like he was able to get and some of the guys that
他们在这方面很有效，特别是在更广泛的领子区域隐藏它，他们知道如何做到这一点。我的意思是，你能谈谈那个吗？或者你，我认为有趣的是，大多数邪教领袖真的很懒，但他们都是关于控制的，而且他们几乎总是某种形式的自恋者。一旦他们是恶性自恋者，那就是真正糟糕的事情发生的时候，对吧？因为他们有一点精神病态。但他们所需要的只是招募最初的几个人，因为那是谁然后会出去做剩下的招募工作。我的意思是，NXIVM的建立是因为所有那些女演员和演员以及其他什么人带来了他们的人脉，对吧？带来了他们的钱。
are they're effective at this stuff especially hiding it in the wider collar areas they know how to do that i mean could you speak to that or what do you i think what's interesting is that most cult leaders are really lazy but they're all about control and they're almost always some form of narcissist. Once they're a malignant narcissist, that's when the really bad stuff happens, right? Because they have a little bit of a psychopathy. But all they need is to recruit the first few people because that's who will then go out and do the rest of the recruiting. I mean, NXIVM was built because all of those actresses and actors and whatever brought in their connections, right? Brought in their money.
他从未离开过那个狭小的区域。就像他在15年里只离开过那个50英里的半径两次。他不在欧洲，也不在这些岛屿上。他就像穿着油腻的袜子躺在沙发上，你知道？完全正确。这些岛屿，他就像穿着油腻的袜子躺在沙发上，你知道，完全正确，他非常典型的那种懒惰的邪教领袖，对吧？所以，嗯，是的，我想，我不，对不起，我忘了问题是什么了。人们的个人创伤是如何被用来控制他们的，当这些家伙是更好的人以不同方式接近人们时
He never left that tiny area. Like he left that 50 mile radius like twice in 15 years. It wasn't in Europe and on these islands. He was like laying in greasy socks on the couch, you know? Exactly. these islands he was like langing in greasy socks on the couch you know exactly he's he's so typical of that kind of lazy cult leader right so um yeah i think that i don't i'm sorry i forgot what the question was how is your you know people's individual trauma used to kind of control them when these guys are the better ones approach people differently
他们可以直觉地锁定你正在逃避的东西，并让你进入那个陷阱。但部分地，我认为，对不起，部分地他们所做的是创造那种创伤，对吧？他们会让你相信你的父母对你很糟糕，他们会让你相信你身上发生了什么坏事，他们才是真正植入创伤的人。我的意思是，他们让你经历，他们让你感觉像一坨屎，对吧？我的意思是，当人们离开时，他们没有自我感。他们没有自尊。他们没有自信，因为所有这些都被打破了。因为即使你据说找到了救赎，可以说，或者有人会带你去那里，他们不接受你本来的样子，他们然后必须把你撕碎，这就是部分，这就是
they can clock that thing intuitively that you're running from and get you in that well but and partly i think excuse me partly what they do is create that trauma right they'll convince you that your parents were awful to you they'll convince you that something bad happened to you that they're the ones who actually implant the trauma. I mean, they put you through, they make you feel like a piece of crap, right? I mean, when people leave, they have no sense of self. They have no self-esteem. They have no self-confidence because all of that is broken down. Because even though you've supposedly found salvation, so to speak, or somebody who's going to take you there they don't accept you as you are they then have to tear you apart and that's part of that's what
灌输过程是关于什么的，就像撕碎那个人，他们弄清楚要按什么按钮，对吧？所以他们，你知道，当我走出我的邪教时，我的意思是，我已经上过大学了，当我走出我的邪教时，我是富布赖特学者（Fulbright scholar）。我的意思是，我已经上过大学了，当我走出我的邪教时，我是富布赖特学者。我几乎不知道怎么过马路。我的意思是，我不知道怎么开银行账户，我不知道，我一直感到困惑，我很害怕，你知道，所以他们创造了那个，嗯，是的，所以，但是，你知道，他们中的一些人当然会诉诸于可能发生在你过去的事情，或者你有一个糟糕的家庭，等等。但是。
the indoctrination process is about it's like rip that person apart and they figure out what are the buttons to push right and so they you know when i got out of my cult i mean i had already been to college i was a fulbright scholar when i got out of my cult I mean I had already been to college I was a Fulbright scholar when I got out of my cult I barely could figure out how to cross the street I mean I didn't know how to open a bank account I didn't I was just mind boggled the whole time I was terrified you know and so they create that um yeah so but you know some of them of course will appeal to maybe something that happened in your past or that you had a shitty family or whatever. But.
嗯，你把毒药作为治愈你带来的东西的解药来卖。但我仍然认为你必须得到那个初步诊断。有些人渴望某种存在主义或神秘的体验，你知道，某种体验。其他人真的只是想要工具来让世界变得更好，他们想成为其中最被授权的人。对。有数百万种表现形式，但是。是的，完全正确。它各不相同。就像什么，你知道，有些人，有时人们说，“哦，嗯，那些只是那些寻求者，你知道，嗯，我们都是寻求者。”我的意思是，我们是，我们是人类。我们是社会性动物。我们想要家庭。
Well, you sell the poison as the cure to the thing that the person's bringing in. But I still I still think you have to get that initial diagnosis right. Some people are kind of longing for some kind of existential or mystical experience, you know, some some sort of experience. Other people really just want tools to make the world better and they want to be the most empowered in that. Right. There's a million presentations, but. Yeah, exactly. It varies. It's like what, you know, some, sometimes people say, oh, well, those are just those seekers, you know, well, we're all seekers. I mean, we are, we're humans. We're social animals. We want family.
我们想要，你知道，就像我刚才说的，意义和目的。并不是有一群疯狂的寻求者在那里，这就是加入这些团体的人。我们中的任何一个人都可能进入这些团体中的一个，就像我一样，你知道。是的。所以这就是人们需要认识和尊重的，你知道，这适用于我们所有人。嗯，我想尊重你的时间。有什么你认为，你知道，如果有人想出去，这吸引了他们？从什么书开始？我们可以链接到你在亚马逊或Audible上的作者页面。而且，你知道，你还有其他项目吗？你
We want, you know, like I was saying earlier, meaning and purpose. It's not that there's some bunch of crazy seekers out there and that's who gets into these groups. Any one of us can get into one of these groups, as I did, you know. Yeah. So that's what people need to recognize and honor, you know, that this applies to all of us. Well, and I want to be respectful of your time. Is there anything that you think, you know, if somebody wants to go out, this appeals to them? What are the books to start with? We can link to your author page on Amazon or Audible. And, you know, do you have any other projects that you'd
想让人们知道并指向他们吗？嗯，我确实有一个非营利组织，我大约两年前创办的，叫“洛利奇邪教与胁迫中心”（Lollich Center on Cults and Coercion）。所以如果人们手头有一些闲钱，他们当然可以去那个网站，lollichcenter.org，进行捐赠。嗯，我至少写了五本书，你知道，就像我们刚才谈到的，我认为把这些书放在书架上是有帮助的，以防你卷入其中，或者你家里的某个人卷入其中，你知道如何帮助，而且它们也很有趣，我的意思是，你不是那种把所有学术内容都去掉的流行心理学作家，但你也不是干巴巴的学术作家，让你觉得，我必须读它，做我的家庭作业。
like to let people know about and point them towards? Well, I do have a nonprofit that I started about two years ago called the Lollich Center on Cults and Coercion. So if people have some free cashling around, they can certainly go to that website, the lollichcenter.org, and make a donation um i have at least five books that i've written um like we were talking about that that i think it's helpful to have those on your shelf in case you get involved or someone in your family gets involved you know how to help um and they're fun too i mean you're you're not like a a real uh pop psychology writer that takes all the academics out of it but you're also not dry academic writer that you're just, I got to read it, do my homework.
是的。在我看来，这是很好的脚踏实地的东西。所以是的，我有我的书在那里。而且你知道，就像你说的，我做了很多播客，很多纪录片，人们总是可以通过那种方式找到我。而且我正在尝试稍微减少一点，只是因为我已经做了35年了，而且因为我的年龄，就像，好吧，现在，亚尼亚（Yania），是时候稍微专注一下了。但是，你知道，我仍然在那里为人们服务，我会继续下去。所以我的其中一个，有两件事，我主要关心的是。一个是出生并在邪教中长大的孩子，因为他们没有社会资源。
Yeah. It's nice down to earth stuff is in my opinion. So yeah, I've got my books there. And you know, as you were saying, I've done a lot of podcasts, a lot of documentaries, people can always find me that way. And I'm trying to cut back a little bit just because I've been doing this 35 years and because of my age, it's like, okay, now, Yania, it's time to focus a little bit. But, you know, I'm still there for people and I'll carry on. And so one of my, there's two things, my main concerns. One is the children who are born and raised in cults because there's no social resources for them.
是的，在我看来，这些都是非常脚踏实地的东西。所以，是的，我有我的书在那里。正如你所说，我做过很多播客和纪录片，人们总是可以通过这些方式找到我。我正试图减少一点工作量，因为我已经做了35年了，考虑到我的年龄，我觉得是时候稍微专注一点了。但是，你知道，我仍然会为人们提供帮助，我会继续下去。所以，我有两件主要关心的事情。其中之一是在邪教中出生和长大的孩子们，因为他们没有任何社会资源。
And when they get out, if they manage to leave on their own or whatever, a lot of them don't know their real name. They don't have birth certificates. They don't know if they have relatives on the outside. They end up on the streets. They're told that they broke laws, that they're a felony because they were involved in sex work, so they can't go to those cops or help. There's a massive number of suicides, which is just tragic. And my other focus right now is to get this concept of coercion understood by law enforcement and the courts, because I can't tell you how many times I'll hear from an authority, well, you know, she's an adult. If she wants to do that, that's fine. And they don't understand what it means to be under the control of someone in that way.
当他们离开时，如果他们设法自己离开或者其他什么情况，他们很多人甚至不知道自己的真实姓名。他们没有出生证明。他们不知道外面是否还有亲人。他们最终流落街头。他们被告知自己触犯了法律，因为从事性工作而背负重罪，所以他们无法向警察求助。自杀人数非常多，这简直是悲剧。我目前关注的另一个重点是让执法部门和法院理解“胁迫”这个概念，因为我无法告诉你我从权威人士那里听到过多少次这样的话：“嗯，你知道，她是成年人。如果她想那样做，那是她的事。”他们根本不理解在那种情况下被他人控制意味着什么。
And the courts seem to understand it when it comes to what they call undue influence of the elderly, right? The old woman gets coerced by the evil nurse to sign over her will to her and stuff like that, that the court understands. But when it comes to this kind of situation, they don't. So I'm trying to work on that and bring together the various organizations that are working on that and get coercion finally understood, which has happened in a couple of other countries, like the UK and New Zealand, although it's still, even there, it still only applies to domestic violence. So it has to be broadened to recognize these types of organizations. Could you apply legislation, something like a RICO
当涉及到所谓的对老年人的“不当影响”时，法院似乎能理解，对吧？老妇人被邪恶的护士胁迫，把遗嘱签给对方之类的，法院能理解。但当涉及到这种情况时，他们却不理解。所以我正努力解决这个问题，将致力于此的各个组织联合起来，最终让人们理解“胁迫”的含义。这在英国和新西兰等其他几个国家已经实现，尽管即使在这些国家，它也仅适用于家庭暴力。因此，必须扩大其范围以涵盖这些类型的组织。你能否应用类似RICO的立法，
law, like with RICO cases, to be used against high control groups, if somebody was an interpiring legislature? Well, yeah, there, I mean, a lot of these cases are RICO cases. The one against Ranieri was, but it's still difficult to get, you know, that's why I get hired as an expert witness to try to explain, or I work with people who, you know, I have a case where I'm going to go to the parole board and help this woman who's been in prison since she was 17 because of something she did that they told her to do. And she's now 70 and sits in her cell and knits and would never harm another human being ever. But she can never get paroled because of this incident from, you know, 60 years ago. So there's a lot of work to be done in the, in the legal field.
即针对高控制团体的法律，就像RICO案件那样，如果有人是立法者的话？嗯，是的，我的意思是，很多这类案件都是RICO案件。针对拉尼尔（Ranieri）的案件就是，但要做到这一点仍然很困难。这就是为什么我被聘为专家证人来尝试解释，或者我与人们合作，你知道，我有一个案子，我将去假释委员会帮助一位女士，她从17岁起就因为他们让她做的一件事而入狱。她现在70岁了，坐在牢房里织毛衣，永远不会伤害任何人。但由于60年前的那件事，她永远无法获得假释。所以在法律领域还有很多工作要做。
Well, and I just mean practically instead of just education, which is great, you know, is there a way that you could take something modeled after like a Rico, like case to actually put something on the books that would let you legally label in a high control group or, or would that, is that not really possible? Does that require too much subjectivity? I think that that would be extremely difficult. Plus every, every state is going to have its own laws. So what we've got 50 States or 52, whatever it is, you know, it's like, that's a massive, I mean, that's what the people who are fighting the troubled teen industry are working
嗯，我只是指在实践层面，而不是仅仅通过教育——教育当然很好——有没有一种方法可以借鉴像RICO这样的案例，制定一些法律条文，让你能够合法地界定一个高控制团体？或者这根本不可能？这是否需要太多的主观判断？我认为那将极其困难。此外，每个州都有自己的法律。所以我们有50个或52个州，无论具体是多少，你知道，这太庞大了。我的意思是，这就是那些与“问题青少年产业”作斗争的人正在努力的方向，
at because those are horrible boarding schools and wilderness programs. And I mean, some of those organizations are fighting for legislation, but some of the legislation that was written only in a sense gives credibility to those organizations. So they say, we're going to regulate them. Well, no, don't regulate them. Shut them down. You can't regulate a cult. Yeah. Did, did you, have you seen any of some of the newer scholarship about how a lot of those troubled teen industries started when the Synanon fell apart?
因为那些是可怕的寄宿学校和荒野项目。我的意思是，其中一些组织正在争取立法，但有些立法在某种意义上反而赋予了这些组织合法性。所以他们说：“我们要监管他们。”嗯，不，不要监管他们，关掉他们。你无法监管一个邪教。你有没有看过一些关于“问题青少年产业”在辛纳农（Synanon）解体后如何兴起的新学术研究？
Yeah. Synanon is the founder. Yeah. Synanon. In my book, I did in my book, take back your life, which just got reissued. I have a whole section. Yeah. I have a whole section on Yeah, I have a whole section on the troubled teen industry. And there's one article actually has a diagram that shows the map of how it grew out of Synanon, how these all grew out of Synanon, and then they branched off. But yeah, that was because it's all about attack therapy, which is what they did in Synanon. Sit in the middle and have everybody attack you. And that's what they do in these troubled teen
是的，辛纳农是鼻祖。是的，辛纳农。在我的书《夺回你的生活》（Take Back Your Life）中——这本书刚刚再版——我有一个完整的章节。是的，我有一个关于“问题青少年产业”的完整章节。有一篇文章甚至有一张图表，展示了它是如何从辛纳农发展出来的，这些机构是如何从辛纳农衍生出来，然后分化出去的。但确实如此，因为这一切都是关于“攻击疗法”（attack therapy），这就是他们在辛纳农所做的。坐在中间，让每个人都攻击你。这就是他们在这些“问题青少年”
programs. And it's just, I mean, on top of other kinds of punishments and tortures. But yeah, Synanon has a lovely history. Yeah, and that industry is so scary because so many of these communities, they're in rural places. They're usually run by one type of religious group or people affiliated with that type of religious group. And they are usually the only tax revenue for these tiny counties.
项目中做的事情。这还不算其他各种惩罚和折磨。但确实，辛纳农有一段“美好”的历史。是的，那个行业太可怕了，因为这些社区中有许多位于农村地区。它们通常由某种宗教团体或与该宗教团体有关联的人经营。而且它们通常是这些小县城唯一的税收来源。
So they're basically just incentivized to cover up murder and torture. Yeah, so I've got two cases right now in Montana. They are, they're in these way out of the way. Sometimes they would take them to islands. There've been one on little islands in the Caribbean. I didn didn't know that all the ones i knew of were american west yeah no most of them are i mean there there were also i mean look at straight which was one of the biggest that was in new york um new jersey there was a one called kids of new jersey that got shut
所以他们基本上只是被激励去掩盖谋杀和酷刑。是的，我现在在蒙大拿州有两个案子。它们位于那些非常偏远的地方。有时他们会把人带到岛上。加勒比海的小岛上就有一个。我不知道这一点，我所知道的都是美国西部的。是的，大多数都是。我的意思是，也有——看看“直线”（Straight），那是最大的机构之一，位于纽约、新泽西。有一个叫“新泽西的孩子”（Kids of New Jersey）的机构被关
down but that yeah but primarily they send them to these remote areas. It makes it, and it makes it harder for them to escape, you know. Yeah. I mean, people have escaped and they're out in the middle of nowhere and then they just get caught again and brought back and then they're treated even worse. So, yeah, people need to learn. There's actually a documentary coming out March 5th on Netflix, which I happen to be in, but it's called The Program. And it'll be about the troubled teen industry. And of course, our insurance companies are paying for it. Why can you not pay for somebody who goes through sexual assault to have a therapist, but I can pay to choose to send my kid, because I found a Misfits album under their bed to the middle of Ohio to be tortured.
闭了。但主要是他们把孩子送到这些偏远地区。这使得他们更难逃跑。是的，人们确实逃跑过，但他们身处荒郊野外，然后又被抓回来，受到更糟糕的对待。所以，人们需要了解。实际上3月5日Netflix会上映一部纪录片，我恰好参与其中，片名叫《项目》（The Program）。它将讲述“问题青少年产业”。当然，我们的保险公司正在为此买单。为什么你不能为遭受性侵的人支付治疗费用，但我却可以选择因为在床底下发现了一张Misfits乐队的专辑，就把我的孩子送到俄亥俄州中部去受折磨？
Can anyone want to speak to me from the insurance company on that position? One of them seems to be a little bit more evidence based to me. That's what they claim to be doing. Yeah. Well, this is great. This has been great, Joel. I really appreciate your time so much. It's so nice claim to be doing. Yeah. Well, this is great. This has been great, Joel. I really appreciate your time so much. It's so nice to talk to you.
保险公司有人能就这个立场跟我谈谈吗？其中一个对我来说似乎更有证据支持。这正是他们声称在做的事情。是的。好吧，这太棒了。这真的很棒，乔尔。我非常感谢你抽出时间。和你交谈真是太好了。
And I will link to all of those projects in the show notes. And whenever you get the courses for therapists available through your own profit, if you'd send them to me, we'll put those out on our social media also. Absolutely. Absolutely. Thank you. And thank you for your persistence. I think we've been trying to do this since last summer. Absolutely. Absolutely. Thank you. And thank you for your persistence. I think we've been trying to do this since last summer. Yeah. You were supposed to kick off the cult documentary thing. We've tried to slow it down, but you weren't the tip of the spear,
我会在节目说明中链接所有这些项目。每当你通过你的非营利组织为治疗师提供课程时，如果你能发给我，我们也会在社交媒体上发布。当然，当然。谢谢你。也感谢你的坚持。我想我们从去年夏天就开始尝试做这件事了。是的。你本应开启邪教纪录片系列。我们试图放慢速度，但你并不是先锋，
but it'll still be included on there. So thank you for your time. All right. Thanks, Joel. Forget All of the beauty is wasted There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但它仍然会被包含在其中。所以谢谢你的时间。好的，谢谢，乔尔。忘记所有的美好都是浪费。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。